has graciously provided
some intro to the into the impossible
podcast music it's playing in the
background
let's see if people are actually out
there
on the web it is brian keating
we are joined today by none other than a
friend
an inspiration to many and that is
garrett lisey
and it all is sounding good let me know
in the chat room how do we sound out
there
all right i can hear myself so that is a
good sign there's garrett lisey garrett
how are you doing today my friend
hey brian it's a it's a great day in
hawaii not sure how it is in san diego
but usually nice yeah it's brutal it's
pretty brutal i mean there's a cloud
over there
i can see out in the distance
and uh we're just gonna reminisce about
some of your early days your formative
years here in san diego
all the way up through to what you're up
to today so first let me introduce uh to
the very few people there's over 100
plus people watching
on youtube right now probably more on
facebook and we will
be joined later on by our mutual friend
dr eric weinstein who is going to
join us for a separate live stream at 2
30 p.m pacific time that'll be basically
when this live stream
solo episode with the world renowned
garrett lisi
ends and then we'll go into a uh
yeah they might get overexposed they
might feel garrett's have been
overexposed
uh garrett lisey is an american
theoretical physicist he
works as an independent researcher
without an academic
position we're going to talk about that
he is a proponent of the balance between
scientific research and enjoyment of the
natural
universe i find that so inspirational
that you can do both
garrett how do you do it all how do you
how do you nurture the
uh inner inner wandering planetary soul
that you have with this
this uh desire that you have to unify
all of physics
well honestly the only way to do it all
is to kind of do it all badly
i i do the best i can well i see you as
kind of the skinny buddha
of physics uh in addition to the
hairstyle which as
we were talking before we went live your
hair is a lot easier to get ready
in the morning each day than my hair
probably i'm also getting less skinny
you know
i put on the cove in 10 as did just
about everybody so uh
yeah yeah i'm less skinny now yeah but
not our friend eric weinstein he is
i'm going to have a beatdown on him
later because he's came out
i promised anyone who comes out of covid
with a six-pack i'm gonna kill
or at least beat them that's just not
right and eric's just gotten he's gotten
buff as you'll notice when he comes on
live
uh anyway you've done uh many things in
your life you started your career here
tell us what uh what is your world line
what brought you to physics what what
makes you interested in physics
and what was your actual career path to
take you into academia and then
out of academia as you are now well wow
um i mean i started out as a kid just
reading sci-fi and fantasy books and
really loving them
and i was also good at mathematics in
school
so when in high school i started taking
my first
physics classes and finding out that the
mathematics i was learning
and kind of developing a facility with
actually applied to describe our
physical world much like
magic underlies science fiction and
fantasy stories quite often
um it was really fantastic it it's like
wow there is a magical language
underneath our universe and it's math
and that was just the moment i was
hooked ever since then
it was uh just diving deeper
deeper into mathematical physics and
how our world works in different ways
that are fascinating
and i just kept going with that and i
also have always loved flying stuff
so i actually started out aerospace
engineering at ucla
but i think it was the first career day
as in the ucla aerospace engineering
where we went down to an engineering
firm and walked out under the floor
of an engineering company and just saw a
wall-to-wall cube farm
of rotund engineers typing away at
computers working on the electronics for
drones and i'm like yeah no
i'm i'm out no way i want to do that so
i think it's the next day i changed my
major
and took on a physics major and then
also added a math major
and then after that it was just sort of
natural to go to graduate school
and i almost went to berkeley but san
diego
um a had better surf and b offered me
more money to go there
really i didn't know that we were
competing with the uh with the bears to
the north is that
oh really wow how do you know that maybe
just with people like you not with
people like me
[Laughter]
um so yeah so actually and that's that's
ultimately how i ended up being able to
move to maui is because i
i got paid twice as much as a normal
graduate student
and graduate students don't usually get
paid much but that was also
having this regent fellowship grant
money given to me
and uh so i took that and in the 90s i
invested all of that in apple stock
and so so that let me uh
and that's what tom hanks did and uh
that was kind of a forest gump element
to it
i just this fruit company it sounded
great so i just put all my money into
that i like apples sure
no it's actually because um steve jobs
company
next had bought apple for a negative
amount of money
and i knew that next had a really good
operating system because i had
been using their workstation to work on
my graduate thesis
and uh i knew it was gonna be awesome so
i put all my investments in there and
steve jobs totally
revitalized the company and uh their
stock went crazy and i was able to move
to maui
and surf a lot which is it which is a
great thing to do if you can pull it off
you know people always ask me it's like
well how do i
how do i spend time working more on
physics and the stuff i love it's like
oh make lots of money in the stock
market and then
go do what you want yeah i mean usually
we hear about survivorship bias in
academia
a lot differently than that horrible
data point
don't follow my example now talk about
your experience here as a triton
at uc san diego who was your advisor
what was your major
focus area was that always the case that
you were interested in theoretical
physics and then ultimately
the decision i you make light of it but
of course you know
i'm sure there was a struggle i'm sure
there was a component of
a fear doubt uncertainty fun mostly
uh mostly by my parents yeah they had
all the comments
and i was fine they just wanted you to
become a doctor you know
well i mean i i i graduated you know
near the top of my class
and they're like oh what's he gonna do
next what's going to do next wait he's
moving to maui to be a surf bomb
what what just happened but uh but no
ucsd i um it was just i really loved it
i moved to a house in wyndency beach
that was just walking distance from a
wonderful surf break that i could go
every morning if i wanted to
and then uh you know drive up to campus
and bike in or skateboard in because
parking is impossible
yeah still is still true yeah and
uh so i started out um i never even had
the slightest inkling to go
into uh experimental physics my my
lab friends wouldn't let me in their
labs because like what happens we turn
this knob to 11 you know
yeah bad things don't touch that but
i've always been enamored with theory
especially on the more mathematical side
and really really fell in love with
general relativity
and particle physics but also with
nonlinear dynamics
and using computers to numerically
simulate things in our world
so my graduate career was kind of a mix
of all those things
and i started out in nonlinear dynamics
but i was also doing quantum field
theory
courses so i ended up using finding a
numerical
solution to a quantum field theory
equation that nobody thought existed
and my advisor at the time was henry
barbanel who was a non-leader science ks
guy but he had some background in
particle physics
he said well why don't you go show this
to roger and roger dashan was the head
of the department at ucsd at that time
and i came and showed it to him and he's
like oh this is really interesting he's
done work on solitons in the past so he
took me on i switched advisors to him
and uh and i was doing particle physics
and working on this soliton solution and
i
you know had to talk with sydney coleman
briefly
and he's like well that's interesting
but it doesn't really make sense
physically so it's probably nothing
and i'm like well that's a little
demoralizing but okay
it's like is this still gonna be my my
thesis or something else gonna be my
thesis i don't know
but then um roger sadly made the
decision for me by
by dying in the middle of the seminar so
he had a massive heart attack in the
middle of a seminar
and um tragic uh there's there was
cpr didn't work i remember putting my
sweatshirt under his
uh his head but uh it was he was just a
massive coronary and there was no
bringing him back
uh so um yeah so that was that was bad
also a testament to keep staying in good
shape
because he was a rather rotund uh fellow
who smoked a back a day so that was
that was also no good yeah i never met
him but uh but of course his influence
looms large even today
yeah yeah he's a he's just a great guy
but anyway at that time
um ucsd had just started bringing bring
in
canon trillgator and a bunch of other
and other string theory people
and they were really going heavily into
string theory
and so no one knew what to do with me
because i was working on you know
solitons and quantum field theory which
is you know
you know far removed from string theory
and they tried to
uh pivot me over to working on adscft
which was all the rage
you know back in the 90s and somehow
grew even more from that so they were
right about
pointing me that way for the popularity
standpoint but the whole time i'm in
you know i'm in uh ken's office going
what does this have to do with physical
reality
they seem to be talking about a universe
we weren't in
and although it was pretty mathematics
and i appreciate pretty mathematics it
just didn't seem to apply to our
physical universe and that was that's
been my beef with strength theory
it's just a a really fancy toolkit
that's really great for doing some
things but there's no indication it
applies to our universe
and all the optimism they had for how
well it was going to do
none of it panned out absolutely nothing
the
using higher dimensions which is an old
idea from inclusive climb that's great
but they couldn't get the standard model
out right
they they couldn't get uh
anything to work without you know super
partners
so they're all these particles they're
supposed to show up none of them have
shown up
and it's just strength theory it was
just a train wreck and i sort of saw
that coming in the 90s and i'm like
you know i've got some stock investment
money
i'm just gonna go do my own thing
and so that's that's what i did and it
was the most questionable decision i've
ever made in my life but it turned out
to be a fantastic one
just to skip out and do my own thing
yeah having the courage to do that we'll
talk about later my patented
final three thrilling three questions
i'll ask you what gave you the
the courage to go into the impossible as
befits the name of this podcast but
until then
i want to go into uh something right now
i i received a book today i get a lot of
unsolicited books and by the way for
those of you joining us it's garrett
lisey on the into the impossible podcast
uh garrett and i are both doctors and we
both recommend you stretch your fingers
to avoid carpal tunnel syndrome
press the subscribe button hit the
thumbs up button and leave a comment if
you
uh if you have a favorite theory of
everything we're gonna be talking with
eric
weinstein in about an hour 45 minutes or
so
but that might be obviated garrett
because i get these books
uh on a weekly basis mailed to my office
here in san diego and please don't mail
me more books because i've got enough to
read but
but here i got a theory of everything
this is from norbert schwarzer i mean
this guy wrote a book i mean he wrote a
paper and and
but tell me first of all steel man
these people find me too brian well i
always get this uh funny comment i'm
sure you've gotten it too
uh you know dr lisey dr keating i get it
you know einstein was wrong
i can prove it and if i am you know if i
do prove it wrong
i will uh share the nobel prize with you
uh but i'm you know not good at math
and i always say i'm i'm probably worse
at math and i told this to adam reece
uh a couple months back and he said yeah
how do you think i won the nobel prize
he
answered those emails but please don't
send those emails uh but seriously this
guy's got you know it's a lot of math
this guy speaks math this is norbert
schwarzer
he's got graphs he's got waves he's got
but but before we get to
alternative theories of everything a
fermat universe is what this is called
uh steel man for me if you would string
theory what is
uh what are the best attributes of of
string theory then i'm gonna ask you to
straw man e8 and then we're gonna go on
to update uh
recent developments in your theory not
only of e8
but also in cosmology as you put it uh
deforming
lead group but first steel man string
theory what's awesome about string
theory
all right well what's awesome about
strength theory is all the surprises
that
uh that came out and strengthened
confidence in the theory i mean getting
a quantum
anomaly cancellation uh in the theory
uh was very encouraging and
i think that's what brought whitten on
board uh when he first saw that and that
that that
really got steam rolling in popularity
um also the idea
of just membranes oscillating in higher
dimensions that's a very flexible and
rich
area to investigate both mathematically
and potentially with the application
physics
so string theory did take advantage of
things that had been very successful
like clues decline theory which is this
idea of adding
extra dimensions to space time that are
compactified
in into very small shapes
and letting the the strings vibrate in
those
dimensions you're able to get things
that look more like elementary particles
as excitations
so it does hold a lot of promise mostly
for the
the quantum aspects also the avoidance
of singularities
so in particle physics when things are
interacting and they come in the
interactive points
i mean anytime you come infinitely close
you get infinitely strong interactions
at least classically so the idea of
spreading things out as
membranes right where everything's just
one membrane inside
a larger geometry allows you to avoid
singularities and that's that's very
appealing
so for all those reasons string theory
was very appealing
the problem of course is they were that
you seem to be able to build everything
with this toolkit except the universe
we're actually in
because explaining why for listeners you
might not be well it's just it's just
not actually very natural
to get our standard model fermions out
um to get uh even to get general
relativity out is
is non-trivial um and all these things
are just
uh it's kind of awkward to get it and
and
they were hoping that like with the
right tweaks you'd get the
uh the masses for the fermions out and
the cqm matrix
and and and mixings and everything but
it's just uh it turned out to be
extremely convoluted to try to get it
and once you take a theory and you have
to tweak it that much to get it to match
up to
known uh known physics you lose con
if you're rational about it you have to
lose confidence in it so
so those are some of the uh pros and
cons of it
before we go on to that i'm getting some
awesome questions from the audience let
me take one right now
i don't want to get too distracted
because i've got so much stuff i want to
get to before
our mutual friend eric comes on uh this
is from
uh you a viewer sibby esky who asked
you a question if geometry is derived
from space-time
and if space-time is emergent then is a
geometric
uh description going far enough towards
a real
theory of everything in other words it's
sort of a recursion or
you know regress here right um
i would say it's not quite right to say
that geometry just
derives from space-time or even that
depends on space-time
i think it's more accurate to say
space-time can be described as geometry
and that
ultimately you have to look to
mathematical description of
mathematical descriptions of geometry
such as you know differential geometry
and lead groups and representation
spaces
and all the all these mathematical tools
and see how nicely they match up
with our known with known physics
and after you do that enough you start
to build a real confidence in that yes
our universe fundamentally must be
geometric
and uh geometric in a very like
foundational mathematical way
because a lot of the the basic building
blocks of
of mathematics in the mathematical
description of geometry
um just applies very cleanly and
directly to very accurate descriptions
of our world experimentally
so you you build up more of an accurate
description that way and then
you have to then figure out how extreme
you go you go about this thing like
is our universe mathematics uh
as uh max tegmark would like to say
that's right or is it you know is it
he's fond of the idea that's the
exploration of all mathematics
um i'm a little more inclined on the
side of i think it's some
especially beautiful mathematics that
our universe is sort of this
uh beautiful geometry come to life and
we want to talk a little bit about
beauty
in reference to a particular critic who
we've all been together with
uh a woman by the name of dr sabina
hosenfelder who is an eminent
scientist in her own right a good friend
a
uh the person you don't want to talk to
when you're contemplating career suicide
because she might just push you over the
metaphorical
ledge and yet we love her and uh she
performs
a very valuable service i think although
i i think and i pointed this out to her
in a twitter battle that we had uh
last week i don't know if you saw the
trolling uh by frank wilcheck
past guest on the show but she put out a
tweet that something to the effect that
mathematic you know beauty
is of no use to physics
and then frank wilcheck wrote back it
worked out pretty well
for me oh that's fantastic which i
thought was the ultimate troll but then
uh
really good then we got into it both
both sabine and frank will kicker
are wonderful people and i i like them
both the incredible amount
yeah and they say the most wonderful
things about you too but i but i want to
kind of quote from
from her you know in that uh she put out
this tweet or this video about you
stephen wolfram who's been a guest on
the show and eric in particular
interesting she didn't really bring up
max who uh we also had a
theory of everything symposium on the
into the impossible channel please go
back and check over the archives
we did that with pbs space time about a
million people tuned in over the summer
but um but you know one of the videos
that actually prompted me to say i gotta
get my friend garrett on the into the
impossible podcast
is this video where she put out like i
don't have time for your theory of
everything
and it really was just that like she she
doesn't look into it
she doesn't think it's uh useful from
the perspective of making progress in
physics and yet she salutes you she
thinks thousands of flowers should bloom
is she just being you know kind to a
friend or is she
really saying something about because it
seems to me if she were to take you
seriously it's almost like this
you know they say the benign bigotry of
low expectations you know she's saying
like i'm not even going to look at it
but it's really good that they're doing
this how do you respond to her
and her criticism of these beautiful
fields that you have just
you know mentioned yourself in your own
words just just two minutes ago
i i think her criticisms are valid and
should be weighed
highly i think that
without experimental checks uh physics
can and has gone off the rails
into just exploration of beautiful
theories
that just don't happen to connect to our
universe and at that point when they no
longer connect even in principle it's no
longer physics
right it's just uh philosophizing about
the way
universe could be using mathematics and
um uh i do like her a lot as a friend
and i think
if you have a if you have a good friend
you can have contrary views with your
friends and maintain a good friendship
it's just that her and i views on beauty
in mathematical physics
are directly opposed i think beauty is a
good guide for physics i think people
have just been
using that uh in the strength theory
direction and saying things like super
symmetry are beautiful
um even willchik's holds that view often
much to his financial detriment
yes but
it's just people have different ideas of
beauty and that's that's valid and i
think
in terms of this let a million flowers
bloom i also support this idea that
people should
uh be exploring different directions and
different ideas what they consider
beautiful
and developing theories to ultimately
apply to the real world but i do also
think
that very much in agreement with sabina
that ultimately
experiment has to be the ultimate
decider
of what is good physics i mean it
doesn't matter how beautiful your ideas
are if they can't even
in principle come back and be tested
they're not
they're not physics and when uh when
people think about beauty i often point
out she makes the tautological kind of
assignment that
physics is theoretical physics and i
point out that almost every i don't know
of a non-beautiful experiment and i
don't mean that literally like oh
looking at a at the michelson-morley
experiment was beautiful i mean it was
beautiful but
if you look at like the transistor
you've seen it probably the first
transistor was like chewing gum
and a big like wire coat hanger it was
ugly but it was beautiful because a lot
of what goes into experimental physics
is
predicated on the fact that nature has
certain properties
namely symmetry in that you know if i
take data from my
simon's observatory telescope on a
tuesday the universe doesn't care if i
took data on a tuesday or wednesday
and therefore if i difference the data
taken on tuesday from the data taken on
wednesday
i should see basically a signal
consistent with noise and so we use the
symmetry
the beautiful symmetry of nature much to
our advantage
in experimental physics so i always kind
of rail against her
basic equivalence that's false that says
physics should not be beautiful
no physics should be it depends on what
you're calling physics
but don't leave that experiment and that
brings me to my next topic
uh why do you think there's so many
theories of everything i mean you just
listed five of them
uh and and yet there's so few
experiments of everything i never get an
email
dr keating i've got this idea for an
experiment theory that will test
you know all of this never get perpetual
motion machines described in your emails
come on
you know we're in california we got
rolling blackouts otherwise
my favorite one is the cat with the
peanut butter and jelly on top you know
just
but talk about some of the other
theories of everything let's let's talk
about that for a second uh because well
i mean
i want to address your questions why do
you get so many more
you know uh theoretical ideas
uh floating around instead of
experimental one and i i think the
the easy question is cost it's just
it costs nothing basically to scroll out
an idea on paper and send it around
or to type something up on the internet
that's that's almost zero cost which
whereas
to build an experimental apparatus that
actually gets
gets at some fundamental aspect of
nature
uh now has gotten prohibitively
expensive for individuals
you you pretty much only get i mean all
the low-hanging fruit has already been
taken
uh over the past couple hundred years so
now if we want to get access
to uh more insights and fundamental
physics it's gonna cost us an enormous
amount well let me just push back with
respect and
great deference but let me push back on
that so if you look at
you know the ultraviolet catastrophe or
you look at the infrared divergences
those were aspects of quantum field
theory that could have been understood
and were
understood in the 1800s in other words
pre-dating and
go back to newton so newton and herschel
observe
that the prism a glass prism can uh
diffract light and make these beautiful
rainbow patterns and you'll get a
spectrum
then herschel took out a thermometer and
put it beyond the red
and demonstrated there was power energy
heat contained in rays beyond the red we
call that infrared
radiation to this day those were tools
literally that you know
my my four-year-old can can can
appreciate so it's not
necessary that all the and just recently
we've seen data had on avi loeb
um recently he's going to be on on
tuesday to talk about his new book
extraterrestrial
he claims that there could be data from
past experiments that could indicate the
presence of
alien civilization so it i don't know
that it's true i think that we tend to
look for the future and say oh we need
the next big hadron collider
we need the future circular collider
then i'll prove my theory right but
in fact there's probably a lot of data
and actually a side project that you and
i and eric will talk about is this
assayer project that i have
to maybe fund the mining of data with
machine learning and ai
of already acquired data in other words
let's not look for
you know the the next few hundred
billion dollar collider to be our
salvation
yeah it's just it's not as sexy to look
for some signal in the noise that other
people have already sifted through and
may have missed yeah but with uh you
know present company
accepted you know most physicists aren't
that concerned with being sexy
in other fields of life okay although
you do pose shirtless in many many of
your videos which i'll salute and we'll
talk about
um so i want to talk about e8 uh you
announced this to great fanfare and as
you know a colleague here by the name of
jorge hirsch
who was the creator of something known
as the h index
which is really the precursor in some
sense although i think jorge you correct
me if i'm wrong garrett but
i think jorge came up with it after
google so in other words google pagerank
effectively does a form of h-index
searching which important samples
papers that are not just by number of
citations but by number of citations
that are
that have that number of citations so
it's sort of a little bit more
deep than just raw a single paper having
a billion citations is not enough to be
as valid yeah
actually i actually ta'ed uh for a
couple of jorge's physics classes
he's an absolutely great guy yeah i love
jorge and he's an iconic class too
and of course sabine doesn't really care
too much for some of the stuff that he
does but
but anyway let's not talk about her
let's talk about what he came up with
this h
index which is the number of papers um
that have at least h citations
and that's your h index so if you have
five papers and they have
five citations h each your your h index
would be five but if only one of them
has five uh you know then your h index
might be one or something like that so
it's the number of papers that have at
least eight citations
when you have this extraordinary
literally extraordinary theory that's
gotten tremendous amount of attention
and uh and with the attention comes
criticism
so what what do you put to the stock of
like how do you weight the
the h index versus the tedx index or you
know
how do you like this kind of popular
meme culture
versus uh the actual currency
of scientific attributions i think it's
uh
really good at what it's for which is uh
measuring the success in the community
of uh contributions in the literature
and for the purpose of of hot
academic hiring like do you want to hire
this person well
their h index is a good measure of
how well received their contributions
are within the community
um except you have to get rid of
self-citations somehow i'm not
sure if the h index handles that well
not really yeah
thank god thank god for my promotion
because
but as an academic metric i think it's
good um
if you look at my uh my rather paltry h
index
for me personally it's both a
combination of
um i haven't published that many papers
and also i'm working outside academia so
i'm not motivated to climb an academic
ladder
in the same way so i'm not motivated to
try to get to boost my h index for any
reason
i'm much more motivated to try to do
better in the stock market
and if i'm publishing a paper it's
because i think i found something cool
and i want to share it
so yeah also um
my my sort of public notoriety
to academic success ratio is
much larger than normal and most
academics would rightfully say well this
guy
somehow got a lot of publicity but he
didn't deserve it
based on his work and i'd say that's
probably valid i probably got much more
attention
than my work warranted my actual physics
work warranty
um that doesn't mean my the work i've
done in physics is terrible
it just means that i've gotten a lot
more attention than it probably deserved
when you think about uh you know kind of
the vogue fashion how much of
the string theory take of the oxygen
availability whether that's funding
whether that's public attention
as you say there's very little of it
that has been
you know confirmed let alone i i should
say like this
there's very little of it that's
possible to confirm
although i want your reaction to
something kamran vapha said on the show
uh just last month which was that
you know when when you come to when it
comes to your time to answer the final
questions of this
live stream i ask each person you know
what would you put on a
billion year time capsule i'll ask you
that so you can start
multitasking processing it right now if
you had a time capsule
guaranteed to last longer than you know
lana key
has been around uh uh what would you put
on and he said the equations of string
theory which i found
absolutely flabbergasting and i love
cameron and he's incredibly which ones
describing what
so let's let's talk about e8 so let's
let's talk about what was the motivation
for it was it something you discovered
did you invent it
what is so exceptional about it besides
its name which i know is a double
entendre as my french listeners will
note
uh what what is so exceptional about it
um well uh
from a mathematical point of view it is
one of the most pretty jewels in
mathematics
that just so and it's not something
that humans really created so much as
that they discovered
because and this idea goes back and
forth and mathematicians are more
mostly platonous and that they think
that uh mathematics sort of exists
independent of physical reality and
but there's support for this and the
support for this is if you imagine any
alien civilization
playing with mathematical structures
eventually they're going to get to
symmetric shapes
of various of higher dimensions and when
they start classifying
different shapes and different
dimensions they're going to hit
essentially the structures of lead
groups
it's just something that's going to
happen without whatever your system of
mathematics is they're going to hit the
structure of lead groups
and you'll see this the stack of lead
groups and then you'll see the
exceptional cases
and among the exceptional cases e8 is
the
the largest simple exceptional lead
group and any
alien civilization out there in whatever
galaxy with advanced mathematics is
gonna sit
is going to hit this grouping of lead
groups and see it so it's going to be
it's something that's independent of
mankind it's not a creation it's a
discovery
and uh what wasn't known is whether this
had
any application to particle physics the
strength theorists had played with it
before because they play with everything
they have huge tool kits and it touches
mathematics all over the place
but uh they
uh the thing that i got lucky with in
finding is that i was looking
at uh specifically at chromions at
matter particles
right and how to get a mathematical
description of them because back at ucsd
i had been learning general relativity
and really loving it and
but finding in my quantum field theory
classes when i hit fermions
this is a fundamental cost you know
constituent of matter
of the universe is is these fermions
which are spinner fields
and spinner fields are just not
geometric the way
a space-time curving space time is right
so they're what's
what's this is there some geometric
description of spinner fields which are
fundamental to the universe
that matches up with child relativity
and there is there was nobody
sort of working in this direction nobody
even seemed to think it was a problem
so i was trying to figure out okay what
are these spinner fields geometrically
in a way that can be synced up with
with general relativity with gravity and
in order to do this um i played around
with higher dimensions in gravity
and which spinner fields uh didn't work
well at all
so clues decline theory sort of fails
when you try to incorporate spinner
fields into them
so then i after and i was just on my own
on an island so after five years i said
uh pitch it just toss out that whole
body of work i don't have any graduate
students so it's just up to me
and then i started looking at okay what
are the other forces and how do they
interact with with spinners and matter
fields
so then i had all right if you take the
standard model fermions
and you interact with them with the
electromagnetic force the weak force the
strong force and with gravity
you get this big algebraic structure
and it starts to look like one thing
with all these you know different
algebraic generators acting on
a one large spinner field and then okay
i started looking well maybe this is
part of one
really big algebra and i started looking
at like large rotation groups
and then i'm a physicist so i hadn't
encountered the exceptional algebras
before
the exceptional lead groups are just
like they don't usually pop up in
physics
but i started looking at the the algebra
for this uh
this e8 lee algebra and the
structure i put together of the standard
model with these different forces acting
on
uh on the matter particles was a perfect
fit
in this e8 lea algebra and not only was
a perfect fit but e8 also has this
triality symmetry
that suggested maybe three generations
of of matter particles could be
described
and that was just that was just freaking
fantastic so that's what's that's what
spawned this uh
this paper and i think it was uh it was
on one of john baez's
fantastic this week's finds where i saw
this first
first saw the sisters from the v8 and
then it was icing on the cake that the
thing's actually pretty
all right so that uh so i went kind of
crazy with uh with lovely plots of
particles assigned to e8 roots and
rotating them in different ways and
showing that it's really pretty and it's
just
uh that was really great and i'm i'm
still very happy with
having found that and uh if i have a
claim to fame i'm
i'll take that one so update us now my
listeners are very curious about the
current status of e8
and then we'll get into the cosmological
implications of e8
and uh possible extensions of that uh
beyond the original conception but
talk us through what's what's happened
since uh obviously
you've you've uh you met a lot of flak
not all of it was because
of you know your courageous you know
kind of persona
and your uh extracurricular kind of
notoriety i'm saying that in a good way
because i i love that you just love life
and we have a limited amount of time
on earth and you're thinking about these
huge huge issues
and uh and i salute that but um but
beyond that so those are the ad hominem
attacks i'm not going to get into those
i think those are invalid
talk about some of the criticism uh
which is necessary because science is
adversarial
science is provisional science is
self-correcting in a sense but science
also has
group think pettiness selfishness
jealousy
so let's ignore those those attributes
of negative
uh attributes but talk about what are
the legitimate criticisms of e8 as it
stands in its current
uh formulation right um the
legitimate criticism and if you look
back at the original paper
um i'll say well here's the embedding of
the standard model into e8
with one generation of fermions and then
e8 has these other parts
and maybe you can use maybe you can use
triality and waving my hands just like
i'm waving them now
to get two and a second and third
generation of matter particles in there
like we see in particle accelerators
okay so so our universe has these three
generations
um e8 has this structure that hints that
maybe those could be
linked to parts of e8 um if you take the
the embedding that does work of the
standard model into e8
and rotate it to these other two second
and third generations maybe that'll work
but it doesn't seem to want to work in
the most obvious way
and the criticism i got was
um this doesn't work at all it can't
possibly work
um and then the theory is just hopeless
from the get-go
can't work and uh that was fine i'm like
okay well yeah that's probably valid i
think it's worth looking at seems
promising
but you know if i'm the only one working
on it fine um but that's not
really what the what the shape of the
criticism was if you look in detail
what the criticism was it was like no
even one generation of fermions doesn't
fit in e8 and i'm like that's just not
right i mean it's right
i mean it's right there it's obvious i
even wrote another paper showing it even
more explicitly
and but the the logic they were
following is
because it has this other piece in it as
well as the one generator
generation of fermions that makes the
one generation of fermions not be in it
and i i literally almost got into brawl
with one of the authors of the critical
paper
because he was using the word in
incorrectly
but so but anyway
um the the embedding of one generation
is great
but over many years i keep kept trying
to work to see if i can get the second
or third generation to work and i
couldn't do it
so i basically gave up on getting all
three generations in e8
and at this point i don't think it can
work so now i've moved on to working on
uh larger structures in which maybe it
can in a different way
well so now we turn to uh more recent
developments which have to do with a
cosmological
interpretation now you know even i can
uh you know gently upgrade you uh for
some of the things you do
which seemed designed almost to troll
the physics community not unlike
uh frank wilczyk did with sabine last
week but
um but for example the uh the title the
abstract
and and normally i don't have time to
read abs the entirety of an abstract in
a
in a live stream like this but the the
paper that you published about
about ea league group cosmology rather
the abstract is as follows our universe
is a deforming
lead group come on garrett you knew
that would set people off uh although i
don't disagree with some of the first
uh first statements that you make to the
best of our current knowledge this is in
the text not the abstract
the abstract is longer almost shorter
almost in the title
that's very rare uh although i have seen
some abstracts where
you know that asks a question in the
title and then the
abstract is no you know so
but uh but the best of our knowledge the
universe exists as a quant as quantized
excitations of a
fiber bundle explain what you mean by
that
okay um our current description
of quantum field theory
coupled with general relativity as we
understand
it is to uh imagine space-time as a
four-dimensional manifold uh with lead
groups
attached at every space-time point
and then also representation spaces
of those lead groups attached at every
spacetime point
and that this whole whole structure
together
is a fiber bundle
and that elementary particles are
quantum excitations
of this fiber bubble
now when you say that this that is the
nature of the universe can you say like
what would be the evidence for that
claim i mean if that's uh
broken down actually what cosmologists
like and keep in mind i'm just a simple
humble experimentalist right so the the
evidence for that
is if you look at elementary particles
these are largely described by gage
theories
and uh gauge theories the the geometry
behind the gauge theory
is that of a principal bundle which is a
lee group
as the fiber over a manifold
okay so so it's this this is the direct
mathematical description
of our known particle physics
okay and it's it's a very it's a very
natural uh
geometric description in terms you can
you can and i use
natural in the mathematical way not it
not in the physicist way
where to to mathematicians
working with geometry natural means it
can describe be described in terms of
vector fields on manifolds
so so this description of gage series is
extremely well supported um
in terms of how you go from the
mathematics of gage theories and
to the mathematics of particle physics
and this is this is where basically
uh my work and eric's work match up
is he's also fundamentally working with
gauge series and i'm also fundamentally
working with gauge series i've just come
up with a way
of basically
deriving the gauge 3 structure
by starting just with a lead group and
allowing that
allowing the lead group symmetry
internally to break so
you allow a lead group internally to
deform
and when you deform a lead group it
becomes
a fiber bundle where the underlying
manifold emerges as a subspace that's no
longer has the the symmetry
necessarily did and you end up with a
gauge field over it as well as a
uh what's called a frame which gives you
your metric for gravity
on the the subspace so it's a really
nice way this the idea behind lead group
cosmology is you can very
wonderfully get all the structures of
uh mathematical structures of a fiber
bundle that you need
for all of modern physics just by
starting with the lead group and
allowing it to deform
so i want to make a general statement um
that i feel that you know people just
take for granted that we need a
uh a theory of everything and let me see
if you appreciate this
uroburro or uroboros like logic where
you kind of the snake eating its tail so
i always hear this and i
i confronted people like uh sir roger
penrose about this
and i haven't really gotten a
satisfactory answer this is the this is
the argument it normally goes like this
uh we need a quantum theory of gravity
because we don't understand gravity
in very strong or the quantum nature of
gravity in very strong
gravitational fields such as at the
singularity of a black hole
or at the uh at the beginning of the
universe if indeed the universe emerged
from a big bang
uh scenario so then i've always pointed
out well both of those things
are for you know forbidden from
experimental evidence via
the uh so-called you know boundary or or
hawking uh or the event horizon in the
case of a black hole
and the uh you know boundary conditions
of the of the
you know initial singularity are also
firewalled off from us
and i had this conversation with john
prescott last week in general
you know that uh physicists should
adhere to what feynman said which is
that
i don't care if your theory is beautiful
i don't care
how uh how logical it may seem to you
if it disagrees with experiment it's
wrong and i said
uh john what if and he's the feynman
professor of physics and a good friend
an influence
and he said well what do you do i said
what do you do if you can't
experimentally test it and he really
said you know try harder
and you know i respect him but the point
that i'm trying to make is
what if that you know what if god hands
you an email
you know it says sends you an email like
that movie god friended me
which you know uh or the tv show god
friended me i'm a religious watcher of
it no pun intended
uh but the point is you know what if you
find out there is no uh singularity
at the beginning of time uh roger
penrose is right there's a conformal
cyclic cosmology there's no initial
singularity and two
that the black holes never exist in
naked singularity so you'll never
witness it therefore
i would say do we need quantum gravity
what what are you saying
um i would say that we don't need
quantum gravity
in a practical sense um
however uh and i agree with you
in that uh the universe did not
necessarily start at some moment in time
it could
have it could be eternal and in fact if
uh
if you sort of follow the argument in
this league group cosmology paper
that sort of speaks to a an internal
cosmology where something was just
expanding
eternally from back in negative infinity
um but
in terms of whether there needs to be a
theory of everything there doesn't need
to be one
but it seems compelling that
as we learn more and more physics as
we've learned more about the existence
of more and more particles that it seems
to have fleshed out
a more complete looking set
so as we discovered more fermions it
fleshed out
three complete generations and and
no more and we seem to have a
and now it's getting harder and harder
to find new particles
and we strongly suspect that dark matter
is at least one if not a bunch of new
particles of some sort
but still it looks like the picture that
we have is getting more and more
complete but it's still kind of a mess
and yeah go on and for for gravity
itself
as you say we don't have experimental
access
to the interior of black holes so
we might never be able to
have access and experiment to such
strong gravitational fields but we could
still
potentially see quantum gravitational
effects even in weaker gravitational
fields
and there are i mean and also you can
argue that
if you just have to apply quantum
mechanics to existing theories of
gravity in some naive way
gravity has to have some quantum
description
in order to be consistent with the rest
of quantum mechanics
yeah right so so just for consistency
um there has to be some uh something
going on in the universe
with quantum mechanics and gravity just
for consistency
and and we don't have a consistent
theory of quantum gravity so that's
why there's motivation to look at it
even if we don't have experimental
access to strong gravitational fields
down at those tiny scales great okay
well we're due to bring in our friend
eric in just a bit but not before i ask
people to
please subscribe to this channel push
the subscribe button exercise your
finger avoid
carpal tunnel syndrome the
perniciousness of which cannot be
overstated uh thank you so much to
garrett who exercises daily
both in musical form and physical form
and as a pilot which we didn't get to
but we will at some point soon i promise
uh
and i wanted to finish up with uh giving
you the final three questions in the
remaining five minutes before we
uh have our friend eric join the join
the chat for a new live stream so people
make sure you tune in stay on this
channel and go over to the
link that says uh eric weinstein garrett
lisey in conversation
theories and experiments of everything
we'll start that in about 10 minutes
but before we do that i'm gonna ask in
the next five minutes
questions of garrett that are the
so-called
thrilling three questions that i ask all
my guests usually you have to subscribe
to my
mailing list to get these answers but
today on a live stream i'm feeling
generous you don't
everybody will get the answers and the
first one has to do with something
called
an ethical will so as you may know or
maybe don't know
but maybe someday we'll find out in
person alfred nobel endowed the nobel
prize
with a dual mandate one was to award and
reward scientists for
discoveries or inventions in physics and
chemistry etc
but another component was that those
discoveries must benefit
all mankind so that was his ethical
will as i call it or in hebrew it's
called a zava ah
and that is uh something distinct from
his material will which left money to
fund the nobel prize i want to ask you
what would you put in your ethical will
and um and it can't be bitcoin so take
it away
what wisdom would you impart to future
generations
the thing jumping to my mind is bill and
ted's be excellent to each other
that's fine actually sean carroll said
basically that in uh
very good okay i'll i'll take that
that's the i call that instead of the
categorical imperative the bill and ted
uh
all right so i mentioned earlier kamran
vapha had the statement about what he'd
put
on a billion year time capsule not
unlike the
giant ominous monolith in 2001 in space
odyssey encountered by
mankind as a early primitive species and
in prehistoric africa and then later by
astronauts on the moon
i want to ask you if you could make a
time capsule and put something on it in
it
uh a surfboard that's going to last for
a billion years what wisdom or what
statement about
physics even as feynman said you know
the so-called catastrophe question
what statement encapsulates the most
possible information in the
fewest possible words what would garrett
lisey say about that
brian honestly i think our existence as
humans is so ephemeral and precious but
ultimately insignificant that i'm not
sure i
there is anything we could impart down a
billion years that would have any
significance whatsoever
all right fair enough i think i think
our our future is humanity
is probably to uh produce synthetically
intelligent robots that go out and spawn
through the galaxy at a rapid rate and
maybe fondly remember us
in some weird uh computer memory way
yeah but that that's probably our
ultimate future on the timescale of a
billion years
in honor of my favorite uh science
fiction writer besides arthur c clarke
of course uh isaac asimov i call that
bry
robot bry robot bri robert anyway last
question involves arthur c clarke his
so-called third law you'll know of
course his first law
is any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic and we
open every podcast with those very words
his second law is for every expert
there's an equal and opposite
expert and so soon we'll have on an
opposite expert in the form of eric
weinstein but i want to ask you
his third statement his third law of
nature
is the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible i want to ask you
and that's the name of the podcast
garrett what seemed impossible to a 20
year old a 30 year old garrett lisi
that because of your courage and your
indomitable spirit
you accomplished it and went a little
bit into the impossible
um you have to try things that seem
outlandish
and make the choices that
are really you see making you happy long
term
even when they seem unlikely but also
hedge
and someone's asking me about bitcoin in
the last 10 seconds are you pro
so so definitely definitely try for the
outlandish but make sure to hedge
so that you'll do okay even if your
outlandish things that you're trying
don't work out perfectly
that's great and you wouldn't tell your
20 year old self to buy bitcoin very
good
okay well i guess the apples wasn't
around until 2010.
garrett thank you so much for going into
the impossible now stay tuned out there
uh please again subscribe to the podcast
follow garrett on twitter i've got his
handle up there garrett garrett lisey
go to the pacific sciences institute
we'll talk a little bit about funding in
academia
the academic hunger games eric and i are
fond of talking about that
and we'll talk about kind of each
other's perspectives on
uh on each other's theories and i'll
give an aviation analog
to that once you guys join me over in
the next live stream starting in four
minutes so now
garrett and i are going to sign off from
this dual live stream and join our
friend eric weinstein stay tuned
subscribe like comment and uh please
join us
in just a couple of minutes thank you
very much
been great talking with you brian
looking forward to eric joining yes